nous passons à la revue de presse
revue de presse signée sandrine gomez
bonjour sanguine un bonjour film
commençons avec du sport avec le coup
d'envoi dans deux jours de la can 2021
mais ce coup d'envoi c'est dimanche à
yaoundé l'algérie qui va remettre son
titre en jeu une 33e édition de la can
on le sait qui a été reporté en raison
de la pandémie la question aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir est ce que le coc vie de
20 nouveaux gâcher à la fête au cameroun
c'est ce que titre ce matin jeune
afrique ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on va
assister une canne un peu particulière
philo mais pas de stade plein à craquer
il y à des jauges 60% à du taux de
remplissage de la plupart des stades 80%
lorsqu'il ya des compétitions avec en
ligne avec le pays hôte il reste
cependant des inconnus quelle sera la
proportion des joueurs qu vide et on
croise les doigts s'il y a trop de
joueurs effectivement que wie der garde
et c'était sain et bien le président
camerounais paul biya on nous dit qu'on
finira bien cette can au baby foot c'est
un indécent de damien glez un excellent
quoi qu'il en soit cette compétition se
déroule malgré tout en vert et contre
tous en lui malgré les laisse ou bleu
soubresauts malgré les cas au titre
libération le journal qui explique que
l'évènement agace les clubs européens
qui voient leurs joueurs partir pour un
cette compétition en pleine saison ils
tentent à chaque fois de retarder leur
départ mais cette année nous disent
quotidien ni les puissants ni les bons
ni la pandémie n'auront pu en venir à
bout l'afrique a résisté à des stars
internationales sur le terrain et sur le
banc et bien il ya de plus en plus
d'entraîneurs locaux pour la première
fois depuis le début des cannes deux
tiers des entraîneurs africains sont à
la tête des équipes engagées dans cette
coupe d'afrique des nations c'est une
grande première se félicite ici le
journal du cameroun qui rappelle que
pendant longtemps et bien les locaux ont
été éclipsés en faveur d'entraîneurs
étrangers souvent venus d'europe dans la
presse aussi le kazakhstan cette
situation et cette intervention oui oui
la question qu'on se pose en la presse
sopo ce matin c'est pourquoi cette
intervention russe les eaux les échos ce
matin vendra au but le kremlin ne peut
laisser plonger dans le cas où un voisin
à forte minorité russophone c'est un
cinquième des 17 millions de casaque
autre raison à ce territoire un porte
sur le plan géopolitique pour moscou
notamment pour ses activités
stratégiques pétrole spatiale et
minéraux et puis vu de russie
l'intervention russe explique pour
éviter nous dit on un scénario à la
syrienne c'est ce que nous dit le site
de l' agence officielle spoutnik la
russie s'inquiète de la situation et du
danger islamiste en asie centrale qui
pourrait s'étendre à ses frontières on
cite ici en diplomate qui explique que
la menace est à prendre au sérieux il
faut rappeler dit il que le kazakhstan
fait partie de l'émirat du turkestan du
turkestan de dh les anciennes
républiques de d'asie centrale ont été
secoué par une série d'attentats
terroristes ces dernières années
l'intervention qui n'est pas sans risque
oui le moscow times nous dit que moscou
se serait bien passé de cette
intervention elle arrive à un moment
délicat en pleine tension avec
l'occident sur fond de déploiement
militaire à la frontière ukrainienne et
de pourparlers avec les états unis
concernant les garanties de sécurité et
puis cette intervention extérieure elle
risque aussi de favoriser et bien une
vague de nationalisme casa qui pourrait
rompre cet équilibre ethnique du pays on
note ici que les précédentes
interventions russe dans les pays post
soviétiques ont vu des pays d etat à me
prendre des virages anti russe on parle
ici de la géorgie mais aussi l'ukraine
alors en cause ce sont ces chiffres
stratosphériques tous les jours plus de
deux cent mille contamination
quotidienne doublement des cas tous les
cinq à six jours regarder c'est le
vertige ans pour libération en une ce
matin il s'interroge on s'interroge sur
le pari risqué de l'exécutif de laisser
filer la pandémie pour viser une
immunité collective en cause notamment
philo mais la stratégie dans les écoles
avec des tests à répétition pour tout le
monde dès qu'un enfant est positif dans
une classe résultats omicron sème la
pagaille à l'école titre le parisien
plus de dix mille classes fermées à
cause de professeurs contaminé
47500 cas positifs chez les enfants et
on parle beaucoup de petits en
souffrance devant les labos merci
sandrine domaine fin de votre revue de
presse fin aussi de ce journal merci à
vous de rester fidèle aux antennes de
france 24